les parachutistes ont eu raison de la
marseillaise version reggae serge
gainsbourg a annulé le concert qu'il
devait donner hier soir à strasbourg
mais il l'a fait d'une manière très
spectaculaire et courageuse seul sur
scène et 100 musiciens il a bien chanté
la marseillaise mais pas la sienne celle
de rouget de lisle parce que mes
jamaïcain ce n'est pas leur problème
yvette de kingston ils ont été effrayés
par les par les déploiements de forces
de police et par les arrêts à la pompe
tu as eu lieu dans tous les hôtels de la
ville je suis un insoumis
et qui a redonné l'avancé yeux son sens
initial
et je vous demanderai de la chanter avec
moi
fort de la pap y y et le jour de gloire
est avide et contre tous de l'ain tea
party l'étendard sanglant t
l'étendard sanglant est levé
entendez-vous dans nos campagnes
une référence aux vins ils viennent
jusque dans nos bras égorger nos fils
nos compagnes aux as
aux citoyens
vos bataillons marchons main en sang
qu un sanguin p habré
[Musique]